vamos a resolver este problema dice sea
un mega el número complejo coseno de 2
entre 3 más y seno de 2 y entre 3
entonces la cantidad de números
complejos distintos z que satisfacen que
este determinante es igual a cero es
igual a ok tenemos que encontrar la
cantidad de setas que hagan que este
determinante sea cero así que vamos a
desarrollar este determinante para ver
que nos queda y después veremos qué
hacemos con la zeta bueno desarrollando
este determinante en la primera fila
tenemos que multiplicar este set a más
uno con el determinante de esta matriz
de dos por dos
entonces nos quedaría z más uno z más 1
x el determinante de ésta que es z más
omega cuadrada que está más o menos
cuadrada por zeta más omega
se está más omega y sería menos uno por
uno o sea menos uno y esta es una zeta
ok entonces cerramos paréntesis
esto es para z más 1 ahora vamos a pasar
a este omega a este omega de acá que le
toca signo negativo verdad porque
estamos porque porque estamos haciendo
un determinante y tiene como patrón de
tablero de ajedrez entonces ahora sería
menos omega por el determinante de estos
4 que se obtienen de tachar esta esta
columna y esta fila entonces sería menos
omega por y aquí hay que poner el
determinante de esta matriz de 2 por 2
que es omega por zeta más omega omega
por zeta más omega menos 1 por omega
cuadrada o sea menos omega cuadrado vale
ok y ahora vamos con este de acá con
omega cuadrada le toca signo más lo voy
a poner aquí en color amarillo y ahora
tenemos que multiplicar por el
determinante de esta matriz entonces
sería más omega cuadrada multiplicado
por omega por uno es omega
- omega cuadrada por z más o menos
cuadrada o menos cuadrada por zeta más
omega cuadrada ok entonces queremos
encontrar las setas que cumplan que esto
es igual a cero o sea las setas que
cumplan que esta expresión es igual a
cero déjame desarrollarla para ver si
podemos simplificarlo un poquito
entonces con color azul voy a hacer esta
parte nos quedaría z1 y voy a hacer el
producto de estos dos nos quedaría z x
zz cuadrada z por omega z omega luego
omega cuadrada por zeta lo voy a poner
como zeta o mega cuadrada y finalmente
nos queda omega cúbica de este producto
y hay que restar un 1 ya eso hay que
restar hay que restar
omega
por aquí nos queda omega por zeta omega
por zeta más omega cuadrada menos omega
cuadrada esto está bueno ya cancelamos
algo y finalmente en amarillo nos queda
omega cuadrada por omega menos aquí lo
voy a poner como mega cuadrada z o mega
cuadrada z más perdón aquí es menos
verdad porque es menos menos omega
cuarta menos omega cuadrada me por omega
cuadrado es menos omega cuarta muy bien
esto de aquí queremos que sea igual a
cero
esto va un poquito para largo pero les
seguimos entonces parte azul vamos a ver
qué nos queda acá es z por cada uno de
estos términos
entonces nos quedarían nos quedaría z
cúbica más se está cuadrada omega más se
está cuadrada omega cuadrada más zeta
omega cúbica menos z y luego es uno por
cada uno de estos términos simplemente
los copió igualitos
está cuadrada más zeta omega + zeta
omega cuadrado más omega cúbica menos 1
ok todo esto es la parte azul vamos con
la parte verde que está más sencilla
sería menos omega cuadrada z menos omega
cuadrada zeta
y finalmente comer a cuadrada z ok y
finalmente va la parte amarilla que
sería más omega kubica omega ubica menos
menos omega cuarta zeta
omega cuarta z y luego omega cuadrada
por menos omega cuarta o sea menos omega
sexta y queremos que eso sea igual a 0
muy bien ya que nos interesa encontrar
los zetas que hagan que esta igualdad se
cumpla voy a juntar esto por potencias
de z vale se va a ver un poco arbitrario
pero vamos a hacerlo para ver qué queda
entonces vamos a empezar con las setas
con las setas cúbicas únicamente hay
esta seta cúbica entonces la pongo aquí
se está cúbica ahora vamos con z
cuadrada se está cuadrada tenemos
esta estas son las únicas que tenemos
entonces factor izándose está cuadrada
nos queda omega más omega cuadrada más 1
x z cuadrada sale bueno ahora vamos con
las que nada más tienen z las que nada
más tienen zetas son z omega kubica
menos zeta ceta omega más z omega
cuadrada menos z omega cuadrada pero
fíjate este está bueno este se cancela
con este entonces ya no nos preocupamos
por él y además está esté menos omega la
cuarta z entonces sería más más omega
kubica porque vamos a factorizar la zeta
entonces omega cúbica más omega más
omega muy bien luego menos zeta o sea
sería un -1 ya los cambio un poco de
orden pero bueno entonces menos 1 y
menos omega a la cuarta menos omega a la
cuarta por z excelente ya que nos
acabamos las potencias de zeta ya nada
más quedan puras constantes bueno
recuerda
omega el cubo finalmente es un número
entonces ya todo lo demás son constantes
entonces déjame ver cuánto nos queda
vamos a vamos a tomar este color rosa
entonces sería más omega al cubo
omega el jugo menos uno este este más
omega al cubo
mega el cubo menos omega a la sexta ok y
queremos que esta expresión sea igual a
cero mira ya separamos entre las cosas
que tienen omega y las que tienen z
entonces ahora sí estaría muy padre
entender a este número omega a entender
que hace vale y bueno para entenderlo
así si lo ve uno de lejos se ve muy feo
pero si nos acordamos de esta fórmula
que dice que es a la teta es igual a
coseno de teta le voy a poner un poco
más bonita coseno de teta más y seno de
teta entonces nos podemos dar cuenta que
este numerito no es nada más que osea
que omega omega simplemente es igual a
a las 2 p
tercios por y que si ponemos teta igual
a dos tercios entonces tenemos coseno de
dos tercios y seno de dos tercios por y
entonces esto va a estar muy bueno y
bueno parece ser como que un poco más
complicado pero no porque ahora va a ser
más fácil elevar omega a diferentes
potencias vamos a ver quiénes omega así
de adeveras alguien en el mero plano
complejo entonces déjame poner por acá
el plano complejo aquí voy a poner y voy
a poner el eje imaginario por acá voy a
poner el eje el eje real ahí tenemos
imaginario
aquí tenemos real y un número de la
forma de ala y por teta es simplemente
el número que tiene magnitud 1 déjame
tomar este línea que tiene magnitud 1 y
cuyo ángulo cuyo ángulo éste está en
este caso tenemos dos tercios entonces
serían 120 grados está acá estoy acá es
dos pi tercios y por lo tanto éste sería
omega y bueno se puede se puede ver
quién es su parte real y en su parte
real
tienen su parte compleja ahorita no voy
a hacer las cuentas pero pero si te voy
a decir quiénes son tenemos que la parte
real es menos un medio y la parte
compleja la parte compleja si esto es
menos un medio este es raíz de 3 la raíz
de 3 sobre 2 perdón la parte imaginaria
es raíz de 3 sobre 2 muy bien entonces
tenemos lo siguiente tenemos que omega
omega es igual
a la 2 p
tercios por iu pero esto de aquí es
igual a menos menos un medio más raíz de
tres entre 2
y lo bueno de ver al número axial verde
de ver al número común
dos tercios por y es que elevar al
cuadrado es muy sencillo tenemos que
llegar al cuadrado es igual a e a la
cuatro tercios pi tercios por y que
simplemente es el que está de este lado
verdad tiene la misma o sea es tenemos
120 grados sumamos otros 120 grados
llegamos a 240 y por lo tanto tiene la
misma parte real sería menos un medio
pero ahora su parte imaginaria es hacia
abajo menos raíz de 3 sobre 2 y pero lo
que es todavía mejor lo que es todavía
mejor es que cuando elevamos omega al
cubo omega al cubo obtenemos un ángulo
de 360 grados y por lo tanto regresamos
aquí al origen
entonces omega el jugo bueno es otra
forma de pensar lo es que omega al cubo
es
a la 2 y 2 p y utilizando esta fórmula
tenemos que sería coseno dedos pin que
es igual a uno más y bs seno del hospi
seno de dos pies cero
entonces omega al cubo es igual a la 2
piqué es igual a 1 y mirad esto está muy
bueno porque si ya tenemos omega al cubo
y este omega el cubo nos quedó igual a 1
pues ahora omega a la cuarta que voy a
poner en este color
omega a la cuarta es igual a omega al
cubo por omega omega al cubo es 1
entonces esto es igual a omega y omega
la sexta es igual a omega al cubo al
cubo al cuadrado que es igual a 1 al
cuadrado que es igual a 1 y estoy
calculando todas estas potencias de
omega estoy calculando estas potencias
de omega porque son las que necesito
para aquí arriba vale muy bien entonces
ya con esta información de las potencias
de omega ya podemos simplificar esta
expresión vamos a ver cuánto nos queda
digamos aquí mira aquí tenemos omega que
es menos un medio más raíz de 3 sobre 2
y quizás no se ve muy bien pero estoy
copiando esto de acá más omega cuadrada
que es le voy a poner menos un medio
menos raíz de 3 sobre 2 y ya eso tenemos
que sumarle 1 pero mirad el raíz de 3
sobre 2 y se cancela con este de acá y
el menos un medio con el menos un medio
se hace un menos uno que con este 1 se
cancela entonces para no hacer una
historia larga
muy larga básicamente esto es 0 entonces
estoy acá se cancela y se hace 0 vamos a
ver qué sucede de este lado vamos a ver
qué sucede de este lado fíjate van a
empezar a pasar cosas padres o mega el
jugo es 1 y aquí tenemos un -1 entonces
este omega el cubo con este menos 1 se
cancelan
pero además omega se cancela con menos
omega la cuarta porque omega la cuarta y
omega son igualitos es esta igualdad que
tenemos acá entonces este con este
también se cancelan entonces toda esta
expresión es 0 y esto también se cancela
y finalmente vamos a ver qué pasa con
las constantes
aquí tenemos omega al cubo menos 1 que
es un 0 y aquí tenemos omega al cubo que
es un 1 menos omega lasexta que también
es un 1 entonces esto otra vez es 0
entonces esto está súper súper padre
porque nuestra expresión complicadísima
que viene del determinante se simplifica
se simplifica a la ecuación zeta al cubo
es igual a 0 y las únicas soluciones o
más bien la única solución en los
números reales son los números complejos
para z al cubo es igual a cero es
z sea igual a 0 muy bien entonces ya
tenemos ya tenemos el único valor de
seta que satisface pero no nos piden el
valor de z nos piden la cantidad de
números complejos que satisfacen la
igualdad entonces como nada más hay un
complejo que satisface la igualdad
la respuesta aquí es 1